monday to hannity tonight breaking news
from the doj's political witch hunt
against donald trump including a
shocking report about the biden
administration's involvement in the raid
at mar-a-lago now the biden white house
absolutely knew a lot more than they let
on they previously denied it plus after
lying to americans about gain of
function research the origins of covert
19 and masks and vaccines and pretty
much everything else dr flip flop fauci
is now jumping ship now we're going to
tell you why fauci's power trip is
finally coming to an end and later
former senior adviser to president trump
jared kushner rare interview he'll join
us give us the behind the scenes of the
trump presidency but first
i have a message tonight for the very
lazy bernie sanders-loving socialist uh
trust fund baby brat in a hoodie that is
now running as a democrat for the senate
in pennsylvania now recently he had a
few choice words for yours truly and
he's trying to raise money off of my
name betterman wrote quote it brings me
no pleasure to ask but are you familiar
with the host of a little show on fox
news named sean hannity it's actually
called hannity anyway fetterman then
proceeded to complain about my interview
with his republican opponent dr mehmet
oz and accused us of spreading bs lies
we don't lie on the show he then asked
his supporters please chip in at least
25 bucks 50 bucks 100 bucks because
quote we got to counter sean hannity
with as much grassroots support as
possible
now this bernie loving spoiled trust
fund baby brat who is all upset needs
your money desperately because i told
the truth about his positions let's see
on legalizing drugs and fracking and
believing in sanctuary cities and states
and getting violent criminals out of
jail
abortion up until the moment of birth no
restrictions at all whatsoever
so instead of accusing me of lying which
we didn't do
john needs to quit his whining stop is
crying man up put on his hoodie defend
his radical opinions and john show me
where you think i lied stop hiding
behind your supporters and begging them
for money trying to raise money off my
name and counter me yourself you can
have the whole hour one-on-one with me
on this program if you want it i'll even
throw in an extra three hours of my
radio show on over 700 stations so come
on in we're ready man up stop whining
come on the show shouldn't be a problem
for john he claims to be a tough rugged
champion of the working man he's got the
goatee wears his hoodie wherever he goes
likes to roll up his sleeves and show
off those tattoos he's a self-made
individual he claims fighting for what's
right
well that's what he would have you
believe here's the reality it's all a
show it's all one big giant force
john fetterman grew up extremely wealthy
he grew up in an affluent suburb of york
pennsylvania he spent a significant
amount of time in college especially
well very expensive schools that i'm
sure daddy paid for but he doesn't
really have much work experience his 13
years as mayor of a tiny little town of
braddock was a part-time semi-volunteer
position it only paid 150 bucks a year
until the age of 49 mr hoody john
fetterman relied on mommy and daddy to
pay for his weed or whatever else he
wanted his yearly salary came from daddy
and a free house from his sister his
sister sold him a house for a dollar by
the way dr oz paid for all the houses he
lives in by working hard like most
people in pennsylvania so make no
mistake there's nothing rugged about
john fetterman mentally or physically
now in may the 53 year old did suffer
from a debilitating stroke he was unable
to attend his primary night victory
party he hasn't been physically or
mentally able to campaign until recently
and at a short and rare campaign stop in
pennsylvania all of 11 minutes john
federman struggled to communicate even a
little bit take a look
we could have picked any part of
pennsylvania where we're going to start
the campaign trail starting let me tell
you
two years ago i was talking to the media
and saying them folks you want to know
who's going to be the next president
do you know what i said
i said tell me one thing tell me who
wins
who wins erie
25 of those counties more votes 25 out
of those 50 there's 54 red counties more
votes more votes than dr oz in those
counties as well too i gave away the
lieutenant governor governor in
pennsylvania the only lieutenant
governor in the history to do that
and you can count
on us
to eliminate the filibuster
eliminate the
filibuster and let's let's get some
stuff
done for america
[Applause]
now john fetterman clearly is struggling
in all sincerity i hope he gets well but
obviously he's not fit to serve the
people of pennsylvania but far more
disturbing are his insane positions on a
number of key issues and has always been
hidden by the mainstream media mob now
here's fetterman's position on oil and
gas take a look at this especially how
important this is to pennsylvania it's
something that has to eventually go away
and i would like to see it you know
transition out and now you have a
president who's building that back and
making decisive actions like
canceling the keystone pipeline which
some people don't support and and i i
think he made the right call
all right mr hoody no fracking no
pipelines no oil no gas that is an 80
billion dollar industry in the
commonwealth of pennsylvania with
thousands of high-paying career jobs in
the energy sector i know you are used to
not working most people in pennsylvania
work damn hard and john fetterman wants
to put all these people out of work and
out of business that would send the
entire state of pennsylvania's economy
into an all-out tailspin and that's not
all it gets worse here's john
fetterman's position on violent crime
take a look
i was on a panel with secretary wetzel
uh earlier before the pandemic hit and
he said something remarkable that i
agree with he said we could reduce our
prison population by a third and not
make anyone less safe in pennsylvania
and that's a profound statement
it's also profound violent crime in many
cities in pennsylvania went up 60
as he was the lieutenant governor
lieutenant governor in other words he
wants to release thousands of violent
felons back on the streets and it's not
just rhetoric during his time as
pennsylvania's lieutenant governor he
tried to free scores of violent
criminals including one convicted
murderer who robbed and killed an
18-year-old girl in order to buy heroin
that do you want that in pennsylvania
and by the way john fetterman also wants
to make heroin legal and accessible
take a look
just like wait a second what are you
talking about like you want to legalize
heroin and why are you talking why do
you care about these things i think it's
important we as a society have all the
options on the table including um needle
exchange which is only technically legal
in philadelphia and pittsburgh and even
safe injection sites that are being
considered like say in philadelphia
john fetterman doesn't seem to
understand the ramifications of much of
anything maybe that's because he was
handed everything in life on a silver
platter so naturally he feels a special
bond with multi-millionaire socialists
his comrade in arms bernie sanders take
a look
that's why i am proud to endorse bernie
sanders today and bernie sanders and i
agree on a lot of other issues too that
are critical to this country's future
whether it's immigration whether it's
marijuana legalization whether it's
universal pre-k or affordability for
college education we stand together as
the most progressive candidates in our
respective races and it's my pleasure
and privilege to stand with bernie and
to have bernie's back
[Music]
what bernie wants to do for the u.s i
want to do in pennsylvania he got a head
start as the mayor of braddock where
under his leadership violent crime went
up the population went down from well
over two thousand residents to less than
eighteen hundred at one point even
fetterman himself was so fearful of
crime and braddock guess guess what he
chases after a completely innocent
african-american jogger held this man at
gunpoint because fetterman believed the
man was involved in a recent shooting
with no actual reason whatsoever i
thought liberals were against that kind
of racial profiling imagine if that was
a republican the outrage from the media
mob would be non-stop but i digress the
good news tonight according to recent
polls this race is now tightening very
quickly dr oz can definitely win
especially when the people of
pennsylvania learn about the phony
hoodie story and and the record of this
guy john fetterman so if you run it easy
about living among violent rapists
murderers or you care about your job or
your taxes or your businesses and you
don't think socialism under joe biden is
working get to the polls and vote on
november the 8th and as for mr fetterman
mr bernie sanders lover trust fund baby
brat who never had a real job and only
campaign for 11 whopping minutes i wish
you well with your health if you're
strong enough to defend any of these
insane positions you are welcome on this
program any night so come on mr bernie
sanders in a hoodie you know show me you
know where i once lied stop raising
money off lying about me because that's
what you're doing hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else